Kanye got dropped by Adidas how do we
feel about it expected right yeah you
can't be the German Sports company
holding on to the anti-semite for that
long yeah it took this long it's
actually kind of like if you think it's
concerning yeah dude Germany's entire
thing right now like their whole
marketing for the past seven years has
been hey we're not with that [ __ ]
anymore yeah yeah yeah yeah and Conte is
just saying all this wild [ __ ] about the
Jews Defcon 3 and they're just like well
let's see
I can't believe Germany let it stainless
was he working with Adidas when he said
slavery was a choice yeah I think so
yeah yeah that's what I've seen comments
about it's like yo why when he was
talking to black people nobody had to
rethink their relationships why didn't
they drop them then that's what I don't
know so that's he was nah go on out go
on Al I'm just saying because the Jews
control the [ __ ] Banks
incorrect soccer club
who's just kidding guys it's Halloween
that was my costume whoa guy
okay uh no go why why did they not drop
him then
when slavery was a choice
I don't think the outrage from everyone
collectively was as loud as it was it
was loud from black people but not
anyone else interesting yeah I have
positive Theory Connie being black left
other people not knowing her to turn me
on boy pause it yeah yeah yeah
you started giving them googly eyes and
[ __ ] I'm like oh okay talk to me now
if I may posit this Theory Kanye being
black left non-black people who are
already like I don't know how I'm
supposed to deal with black issues I
don't know what's okay and what's not
most people are like this guy's out of
his mind but I think objective people
were like I don't know what I'm supposed
to do here yo that's interesting it's
like black people can be racist towards
black people in a way more acceptable
way like Jews can make Jew jokes Jews
can say bad [ __ ] about Jews maybe the
Jewish Community is saying that's [ __ ]
up but for whatever reason it seems more
uh distasteful when one group is
accusing another group of something or
being mean to another group and you've
seen it with these uh NBA team owners
yeah the dude of Phoenix Suns said the N
word out sell your team Sterling out
exactly right and canceled by other Jews
mind you if Jews don't know the
basketball teams and they're seeing
these other Jews was do some racist [ __ ]
and they're kicking them the [ __ ] out
yeah what happened to that loyalty yeah
why aren't the boys coming together
right right you know what I mean so it
is kind of interesting I think I think
what's so funny about this situation is
Kanye is going like see look see see
who's really in control and it's like
brother this happens to every single
person that has ties to a major
corporation that is afraid of being
radioactive because of the actions of
one person yeah that's all this is does
do these big corporations really give a
[ __ ] about the average person no they
got little kids sewn together they're
close yeah they don't give a [ __ ] what
they care is if the world is going is
Adidas an anti-semitic company and
they're a consumer it's in the
consumer's face to say do I want to
support this that Sweatshop [ __ ] it's
behind closed doors we all hear about it
none of us really want to know we don't
bring it up benefits us exactly it helps
yeah is Amazon killing a mom-and-pop
store sure absolutely and my mom and pop
yeah I mean I get my [ __ ] cheaper and
delivered right tomorrow even if it was
I'ma probably keep buying because it's
cheaper everywhere else they beat them
in every way iPhones every one of us got
a slave machine little kids in China
were ever making it we're just like I I
don't see it and going on drink Champs
and saying anti-semitic [ __ ] I cannot
Escape it was [ __ ] up I I know that
they make it yeah we know but we don't
see oh yeah it's the video do you
remember Ray Rice you don't know I don't
know oh it's the Ray Rice when he was
dragging his girl around we yeah we knew
he hit his wife but when we saw it it
just affects us differently yeah that's
just what it is and it's a shitty thing
about humans but we can be willfully
ignorant very easily if we don't see it
yeah once we see it it's different yeah
yeah I don't know I just think it's I
don't think it's that shocking what's
happening to him yeah I can't believe
that he's shocked by and he feels like
it's some sort of like uh
justification for what he's saying this
whole time yeah possibly he's doing it
intentionally to get out of the contract
okay so I was talking to somebody that
we know and he was like this is actually
Kanye's goal but he didn't probably he
probably didn't think that he was going
to become this radioactive and that
might hurt his long-term Vision right
he's having some trouble exactly I mean
if you see it he's on drink Champs going
like I can even say anti-semitic [ __ ]
and Adidas won't drop me he's trying to
get this is the Assumption he's trying
to get out of the Adidas contract he's
daring Adidas to drop them because why
does he want to get out of the Adidas
contract because he is Go-go well he
feels that he's built it uh Yeezy up to
a billion dollar brand now he no longer
needs to be Shackled to Adidas and have
them tell him what he can or can't do
and make the knockoffs of his [ __ ] and
make a non-composition and he wants to
get that shoe Revenue I'm sure probably
so now here's the thing he says all
these crazy things he gets out of the
contract right now he's a royalty deal
with Adidas right so they got to pay him
but what's beautiful about the deal he
got with Adidas is that
they make all his [ __ ] they have the
factories they have the stores they have
the distribution right they have all the
websites they have everything set up
making a factory getting a factory to
make your [ __ ] getting all those skus
done getting all these things made he
has thousands of employees at his hands
at Adidas yeah right
you remove that Kanye is just that kooky
creative guy that goes on all the
podcasts that has all these ideas but
who knows how to actually yeah he's an
idea man he always needs daddy like he
said he admits he's an idea man and
that's why when he tries to do things by
himself he lost 53 million dollars when
he did the fashion Thing by himself he
lost all the money when he partners with
somebody who's a great businessman all
of a sudden he can create some
absolutely amazing things he's done a
great job in the music world he's done
an unbelievable job in the fashion world
I'm sure that he would continue to do
great in whatever business Endeavor he
got into with the Creative Vision and
someone who was all about that business
because Connie's the type of person
that's going to say make these [ __ ]
sneakers and then they're going to come
back and he's going you know what I'm
not feeling those anymore let's scrap
all the sneakers you need someone at a
corporation that goes that's not how
things work yeah you agreed on these
models and this is what we're going to
put out and next time make them the one
you want exactly yeah and then sometimes
those miles do well and then Connie's
like I knew I was right about making
those models right right so I wonder if
he's trying to get out but now he's
maybe done too much damage to get
another investor or partner because
who's going to invest in them now maybe
the Saudis or some middle east person
who doesn't have that much Sympathy for
the Jewish polite right but the average
like American or european brand is not
going to dump a few hundred million
dollars into Kanye West to build out
Yeezy also re-establish those
distribution what do you think I'm just
saying it's like when you see his track
record like yes it's volatile it's risky
to get in business with him but the
upside can be good as well so like I
think brands are going to see this
Behavior they're going to wait a while
wait till this [ __ ] dies down a little
bit maybe let them put out like a a fire
album or some [ __ ] like that and they'll
be at like they'll jump at the chance to
connect so he needs to cure his
reputation first
once he's cured it I think you just need
some time to go by and the time will
cure the reputation yeah got you but but
first things first is cure the
perception
yes Al you don't think so like if you're
if you've seen well you're you're black
and you guys forgave them for saying
that
so then no I mean that's sincerely like
we're you know I don't think what he
said was as bad as the anti-semitic
comments that he made really slavery was
a choice ah yeah yeah actually that was
pretty bad yeah yeah but but like that
was a time period I think I stopped
wearing any easy stuff I cut out the
albums for a while but like I've really
distanced myself from everything Kanye
because I was really so upset by those
comments and then I and then after time
went by and the music started to
introduce itself back into it and then
yeah I forgave them he never said he was
wrong he never stopped [ __ ] with
Trump like that's true he's hold true to
all the things that you're saying that
you were offended by yeah and you've
given him a pass yes
I'm curious the world will do that and
uh
they forgive Mel Gibson did they no he's
worldly he's in the independent circles
like he's been able to like get back
together someone like a famous Jew like
came out was like we gotta forgive Mel
Gibson we gotta like move past The
Passion of Christ made a billion dollars
and they was like listen there's some
forgiveness here there's a sequel that
we hear about that would be really good
I think though that the version besides
like him going away uh for a while
there's going to be some type of factory
that he could do it independently he can
be doing easy drops that'll be super
successful they'll still show like he's
not gonna happen though that's the thing
like he's not the person to build these
relationships with these factors you can
link with them yes there's so many
factories in China actually set up to do
this to connect with it I don't think
there's the biggest leap to do the type
of distribution that Adidas has no
that'll take a while but there's a
version at a certain scale that he'll be
able to kind of immediately go in a
smaller scale I think that is absolutely
possible and there's no question and
maybe he could make even more money at a
smaller scale because he's keeping
everything that's possible but it's
undeniable that he needs factory
connections creatives to make the stuff
and also who might want to work with him
right now if you're an up and coming
designer like a true brilliant guy who's
on the cusp of working with a Louis
Vuitton or working with a I don't know
Balenciaga whatever these companies and
then Kanye a year ago said come work
with me you'd be like well [ __ ] yeah
let's do it now you're like that might
ruin the rest of my career yeah and this
guy might burn out he might fire me he
might hate me and that's another thing
to consider in terms of burnout Adidas
owns everything that uh Kanye has put
out they are all Jesus colorways they
own the name they own everything so now
you're banking on can Kanye make new
[ __ ] as hot as what he made with Adidas
and I could just be some Boomer [ __ ] but
I'm looking at his new stuff a lot now
and being like yeah
and I don't think the heat is there I'll
give you pushback on that I think he can
I think that he has and if it's not the
Creative Vision it is the confidence to
push it through I mean like fashion is
arbitrary yeah right like sometimes
what's cool now will be uncool in a
matter of years legit uncool yeah so
there is no one thing that defines cool
it's are the cool people wearing it and
Kanye had the ability to influence other
cools to wear it now the question is if
he's released his grasp on those
influencers then he can't convince
people to wear the stupid boots or
whatever the [ __ ] it is now think about
this with those influencers a lot of
them want to be Hollywood types they
want to be in the industry in some form
exactly there's a lot of Jews in the
industry I'm not saying they run it or
do it with an agenda damn sure a lot of
them so if you if they're looking at
every person like this [ __ ]
wearing Yeezys to my meeting or I see
him on Instagram with wearing all this
Kanye West [ __ ] I don't need to [ __ ]
with this guy will they take the risk of
costing themselves that relationship
because they're so wearing the fashion
of somebody who's on the record as being
anti-semitic this is a time thing people
wear Armani now and that [ __ ] they were
like designing Nazi uniforms you're
talking about 80 years ago yeah I know
so give it three years I think people
will be like oh yeah I remember that I
mean the Volkswagen is people's car it's
literally
Hitler yeah yeah no I agree I do agree
that in time it will pass but again a
lot of time has passed since World War
II now it was way worse but we're
talking 80 years multiple Generations
Connie ain't not gonna be putting out
fashion in 80 years unless I'm telling
you people's attention span yeah they'll
be worried about something else in the
future and the people love clout and
you're still going to have that clout
like he can Garner attention we're still
talking about him right now and he has
an unbelievably entertaining way of
talking like whether you like it or
don't like it he is wildly entertaining
like I was watching Alex Freeman it like
I'm watching it I'm just laughing hey
don't say Jewish media
there's a few dude he has this one thing
that he goes he goes I knew uh I knew
Kim would never love uh he goes I knew
Kim would never love uh uh love Pete and
not because he's ugly but because she
likes black guys that not because he's
ugly is the most unnecessary thing but
that is him being petty and angry and
just he just wants to call Pete ugly
yeah do you know what I'm saying ain't
the best looking [ __ ]
the fact that he put himself with Reggie
Bush but he's like yo she got a child
yeah
that's how racist Connie is towards
black people he thinks they all look the
same literally Reggie Bush he also she
also left out her first husband who
looked nothing like them right Chris
Humphrey but razier Reggie Bush and me
that's a good ass boy looks nothing like
the first guy that proposed might might
look like the guy the music guy what's
his name he was like a producer [ __ ]
yeah I got this one anyway but uh yeah
Kris Humphries look nothing like him
that being said very short-lived
relationship well yeah yeah yeah fair
enough but marriage yeah yeah I think
it's a
excuse me yeah I think it's a I think
it's an interesting time it depends if
he persists with the attitude and the
behavior yeah I feel like somehow does
like a whole apology tour does like a
movie with Jewish producer like yeah
some type of like major Act of
Retribution to like the Jewish community
and Society at large and then just kind
of chills for like a year I think he'll
be back in the fold he'll build a
partner with an independent business
person that will get the contracts with
the Chinese factories he'll be able to
do the marketing push and it'll even be
more exclusive like the price of yeezy's
already going up because they're not
producing them anymore oh wow yeah he's
gonna build a drop [ __ ] it's like oh
there's only a thousand of these getting
made versus Adidas global distribution
yeah he's gonna be able to keep all of
it it's all going to go up no it
absolutely could work the question is
how radioactive will he be and will
people want to work with him and if it's
profitable enough and [ __ ] has died down
enough in a year then maybe they will
and also based off the current attitude
like on social yeah I don't think enough
people are not [ __ ] with them that he's
not going to be profitable here's
something no here's something about
social I think that we need to
understand and he's doing what Trump did
brilliantly and I think people often say
this and they use that as like a way to
discredit people and I'm not but
Trump tapped into
passionate groups that had no mainstream
representation and he gave them a voice
and the thing about having no mainstream
representation is when you do you
forgive the other [ __ ] they say because
you're just so excited that they're
talking for you right like so for
example there's single issue voters like
there are people who are like I do not
believe in abortion I don't go [ __ ] what
you want to do with the economy I don't
care what you want to do about
immigration I do not believe in abortion
so if you tell me your abandoned
abortion you could say whatever the [ __ ]
you want about the Jews you could say
whatever the [ __ ] you want about the
blacks as long as we're not born I'll
vote for you those anti-semitis that
like Ben Shapiro love them yeah
absolutely love them and he's gonna have
to deal with that that's that's the next
thing that's a very I don't know why are
the why are there anti-summits alive
because he's on their time he's on their
side diagram he's got some crossovers
they don't like that he's Jewish but
they love that he's conservative and
he's fighting for conservatives he's
giving them all great points and he's
he's like telling them what to say to
their friends and like giving them
arguments like he's making them
Democrat and 25 percent would be
conservative and so but you don't think
there's people that have prejudice
against Candace Owens that happen to
like her or like watch her stuff no
there's people who don't like black
people yeah but love that Candace Owens
you're giving them all the talking
points against black people and not all
or even most but there are some yeah
yeah this is not everyone but there are
these groups and what I was saying is
Ben is going to have to work with that
because now that he is the platform the
daily wire is he fostering and aiding
and helping and Fanning the flame on
these feelings of these groups and are
these groups now emboldened with their
anti-Semitism and as that happened it
does has he aided 10 to it 20 to it
maybe or is he giving them like better
footing to not go farther into that or
sure sure so uh boy what were we just
saying that before you brought that up
that there's people that are willing to
look past this [ __ ] so as long as that's
awesome and I think what Kanye did is he
tapped in into a bunch of of groups
specifically with the thing that he's
been talking about like drink Champs and
all different podcasts that are
underrepresented anti-semites number one
they don't identify as anti-semites
they're not like we hate Jews they're
like Jews run the media yeah Jews run
Banks and if you criticize them you'll
be lose everything your house is gone
exactly so they don't they're like we
don't hate Jews this is just the fact of
life and the fact that nobody else sees
this or says this is very frustrating
and then one of the most famous people
on the planet
says it now he can do no wrong right and
not mine but in there yeah absolutely
same thing with the George Floyd
fentanyl thing so all these people who
believe George Floyd only died from
fentanyl right
are being told that they're liars every
single day by the mainstream media they
truly believe it was only Fentanyl and
every day they're told they're Liars
they're stupid they're idiots they're
conspiracy theorists and then one of the
most famous people on the planet goes no
this is what happened
your God and I've spoken to some of
these [ __ ] they've all said
because they were criticizing me so I
was dming with them and I was like yo
what are you really upset about like
what do I do why are you so angry at me
and they all said literally they all go
listen Kanye's an idiot but he's right
about defense and all things you gotta
look at it so they're using Kanye
they're just finally being agreed with
yeah yeah sorry do you what you said
reminding me of a question I had about
the Candace Owens okay you think calling
it uh the rise of BLM and going at this
black lives matter organization that I
think all of us felt like was [ __ ]
for a while and then giving us all this
evidence of why it's [ __ ] and
vindicating that made people believe the
George Floyd fentanyl thing even more of
course because it's like a smart yeah
just one nugget about George Floyd dying
for Fentanyl and then the rest is BLM
bashing I think if you hate what BLM did
like if you felt affected by it and I'm
sure that there's like listen there's
people who have seen what cops went
through because of the rhetoric they
have cops in their family got their
stores they got their stores [ __ ] up
or their friends stores got [ __ ] up
they're they're like legitimate reasons
to feel attacked by the movement just as
there are legitimate reasons to feel
attacked as a black person yeah right so
I understand the frustration so you're
willing to discredit that in any way and
then one of the most influential people
on the planet comes out and says the
thing that nobody says and you're not
supposed to say black dude yeah and a
black guy so you get to feel scot-free
right it's not some [ __ ] white guy
with one hand in the air who's usually
saying it this is the coolest black dude
yeah is saying it so now you're like
yeah of course I'm gonna support this no
matter what anybody disagrees with him
[ __ ] you and I think he tapped into a
few of those things and finally those
groups came out of the woodwork they're
like okay we it's safe it's safe outside
we got a cool powerful guy talking our
[ __ ] we never had it before so we had to
be quiet and uh it's an interesting
strategy yeah yeah he really he sees
Trump's Playbook and he's following it
to the T yeah yeah